je vais vous parler aujourd'hui des
écouteurs des nouveaux écouteurs de wang
plus ce sont les ouates plus de l'aide
soit rs 2 j'ai déjà parlé ya pas
longtemps mais what plus wireless
wireless un dur à prononcer et je vous
parle aujourd'hui de cette deuxième
version cette année en 2010 9 points de
plus a vraiment mis le paquet avec un
mois de plus cette pro qui vraiment très
très très très long qui est juste là qui
est vraiment très bon smartphone journée
et léger j'en ai déjà également parlé le
one piece 7 qui est très beau fronde a
déjà parlé tout ça en équipe et on a un
matelas de grosse boîte
donc il ya de quoi faire donc si vous
connaissez pas encore ces produits de
mittal et visionner les tests comme ça
vous serez tous vous resterez vraiment
fait très très bon boulot c'était cool
bon pack des précédentes
il faisait pas un bon boulot
actuellement un bon boulot mais cette
année ils ont mis la barre encore plus
haute en ayant un bon petit monde repose
sur du flagship killer mais là on
propose cette fois ci carrément du fac
si ça c'est pas ça c'est cool
et justement ils sont dus au fait à peu
près la faune si ble ment la même chose
avec eux nos écouteurs sans fil qui ne
sont pas des trouvailles en l'aise je
tiens à le préciser
ils se sont dit voilà on va quand même
apporté des améliorations significatives
du coup le prix a aussi augmenté on à 99
euros maintenant sur les belettes soul
wireless deux de moins de plus serait
qu'un beau travail qui a été fait au
niveau du produit en lui-même au niveau
de l'amélioration également du point de
vue purement technique du produit
il ya dans des points positifs il ya
aussi des trucs un peu négatif je vous
fais un bilan un peu tout ça comme ça on
pourra vous faire votre idée par vous
même
oui
[Musique]
avant toutes choses brillantes et que
j'aime bien c'est moi non plus et le
travail qu'ils font toujours au niveau
du pack hadji il ya vraiment toujours un
très beau packaging qui est fait très
beau boulot marketing et une fois de
plus sur ce produit là bas il déroge pas
à la règle
ouverture à plusieurs niveaux vous
l'ouvrez voler normalement le petit dos
des écouteurs qui est là normalement qui
apparaît directement ici alors vous
l'ouvrez comme s'attaque fruits sûrs
musique créative together with our
community health toujours ce côté de la
la bouille en gros le côté de la
communauté qui est toujours mis en avant
sur une plus vous venez ensuite l'ouvrir
ici up paf vous arrivez petit guide
d'utilisation pouvez retrouver ci à
l'intérieur là vous avez normalement
votre pochette dans lequel faut ranger
vos écouteurs vous avez juste le petit
bout qui dépasse qui y insérer ici là
vous avez les différentes tailles pour
vos oreillettes convenir régler ici vos
petites oreilles donc c'est vraiment
cool ça c'est à l'intérieur là vous avez
un petit câble de recharge qui est en
usb type c'est moi j'utilise celui de
mieux du mouvement de plus sept pros
dont je peux utiliser celui là vous
rechargez votre charge c'est vraiment
très très très très rapide vous savez ce
petit étui qui est en partie ici aimante
et qui est vraiment cool wen plus c'est
toujours un très très beau travail au
niveau marketing au niveau packaging
faut que je skie vraiment très sympa
mettre vraiment en avant le côté
communauté ça c'est un point qui est
extrêmement important chemin de plus
pour au final vous apporter une
expérience extrêmement personnalisé
vraiment gratifiante dites moi ce que
vous en pensez comment vous trouvé
l'expérience entre on va ouvrir des
produits bovins de plus le côté
packaging croyez-moi je voue beaucoup de
produits il ya vraiment beau boulot qui
est fait en tout cas là dessus un bel
effort et ça c'est vraiment cool parce
que ça augmente aussi le coût du produit
à la fabrication de réfléchir toujours l
expérience d'utilisateur comment évalue
ouvrir comment ce qui va venir découvrir
son produit c'est un côté un peu et
feuillages côté un petit peu sensuelle
ça c'est assez rigolo
voilà pour la partie packaging le
produit en lui-même est assez sympa vous
avez un tour de cou vous venez le
positionner ici autour de votre cou
jusque là plutôt logique point qui est
cool c'est que ils sont aimantés donc
lorsque vous les utilisez pas eh bien
voyez ils peuvent rester comme ça autour
de votre cou ça ça marche vous allez une
petite télécommande pour me remonter le
sondé ses leçons
vous avez ici vos deux batteries ici de
quoi venir recharger votre casque
forcément en usb type c'est un petit
bouton ici pour le double appareillage
on
dans quelques instants comme tous types
d'écouteurs comme ça vous le prenez vous
le mettez et vous venez la série dans
votre oreille je pense que là je vous
apprends pas alors le secret pour moi
pour ces produits là déjà c'est de
trouver le l'embout qui correspond
vraiment à la forme de votre oreille à
l'ouverture de votre oreille maintenant
il faut bien finir tourner un peu dedans
pour lacérer correctement pour être sûr
qu'ils soient bien à l'intérieur de
votre oreille premier truc qui est
positif lorsque vous avez bien acérées
comme ça dans votre oreille c'est
l'isolation passible garder ça vient
bien fermer ici votre conduite ça c'est
un point positif parce que c'est
beaucoup un petit peu de l'extérieur ça
me force à parler un peu plus fort ça
vous coupe un petit peu l'extérieur a
refusé dans les transports en commun
dans un endroit un peu bruyant c'est pas
aussi intéressant et aussi bons qu'ils
nous laissions active avec un casque un
règne sans bruit néanmoins c'est quand
même pas mal
il faut quand même plutôt bien à faire
de ce point de vue là ça c'est un point
qui est très positif en tout cas en ce
sens en termes de confort trouve qu' on
est quand même plutôt bien assez confort
dans les oreilles une fois de plus ça va
dépendre de la forme des oreilles de
chacun ça va dépendre du réglage vous
allez voir qu'ils ont bon vous allez
choisir
mais d'un point de vue purement confort
c'est bien alors maintenant il ya deux
choses et ce tour de coucher un toujours
un peu dubitatif la maison je suis pas
sûr que en europe en france soit
particulièrement bon avec ça d'ailleurs
dit moi si vous êtes hors de france
est ce que si vous utilisez ce genre de
petit casque dix tours du coup est-ce
que ça s'utilise beaucoup chez vous oui
ou non je suis pas sûr en tout cas en
france
je pense pas ça s'utilise beaucoup en
dehors des solutions de running après ça
peut être amené à évoluer mais néanmoins
pour aller faire du sport
ça peut être vraiment bien vous le
prenez vous le posez comme ça il est
toujours attaché à votre cou et même si
vous en avez une oreillette qu'ils états
ne vous ne perdez pas très sympa est
extrêmement positif et plutôt bien dès
lors vous avez trouvé une fois de plus
le bon réglage pour besoin il faut que
ça bouge pas c'est vraiment cool - qui
est sympa c'est que c'est extrêmement
facile appareiller si vous avez un
smartphone de one plus one + 7 points de
plus cette problème les générations
précédentes c'est extrêmement facile
vous prenez vous les ouvrez vous les
allumés vous prenez votre smartphone
vous allez dessus ça va le reconnaître
directement sa propose de les appareils
est extrêmement facilement c'est
vraiment très pratique et c'est toute
l'expérience qui est vraiment génial
café wang plus là dessus c'est très
facile après si vous avez un smartphone
d'une autre marque rassurez vous ça
marchera également il vous faudra par
contre l'appareillage un peu plus
standard vous êtes dans vos paramètres
bluetooth vous la trouvez vous les
connecter ça marche aussi très très bien
à savoir quand vous avez dû
tous 5.0 donc vous avez d'appareillage
qui est extrêmement facile la collection
plus est vraiment stable donc deux
points de vue là aussi il ya une vraie
belle expérience utilisateur que je veux
mettre droit si je vous mets travers ça
va pas vouloir changer dix minutes vous
repartez pour 10 heures d'écouté
recherche très rapide très bonne
autonomie très bien géré vous avez la
varde charge de wang plus qu'à vous
rechargez extrêmement rapidement donc ça
c'est vraiment aussi extrêmement cool
qu'ils sont compatibles
qualcomm a pété x hd est ce que ça va
vous apporter réellement c'est une
meilleure qualité audio vous avez
également de la suppression de bruit
grâce à quoi comme cvc
la qualité audio je vous dis tout de
suite elle est bien elle est correcte
elle est convenable on est serein un
cast qui coûte un peu moins de 100 euros
99 euros c'est bien on va pas avoir une
qualité audio premium
il faut vraiment comparer aux produits
qui sont comparables dans cette gamme de
prix entre eux je dirais 100 euros 120
euros 150 euros on est vraiment dans
cette idée là dans ce dans cette idée là
global à côté de ça l'expérience audio
est assez qualitative ce que je vous
conseille tout ça vraiment optimisé
c'est d'utiliser si vous en avez un
smartphone de one plus one + 7 pro ça
sera très très bien moi non plus est
c'est très bien si vous avez autre chose
ça marchera on va le faire un petit peu
différemment
je vous explique de base lorsque vous
l'écoutez comme ça je pense qu'on a un
spectre qui est assez large tournée
médiums aigus les aigus sont assez juste
assez précis les médiums sont corrects
on a un peu grave mais c'est pas un truc
de fou on peut avoir en fonction des
réglages que vous avez de base certains
si bilan au niveau des aigus vers les
blessés se voyait laissons un petit peu
plus aux alentours de 6 kg 7 kg c'est
pour ça qu'il est important à mon avis
derrière de venir régler vos équaliseur
en fonction de ce que vous souhaitez
entendre jouer en exemple son nom one +
7 pro ce qu'il faut faire c'est aller
ici dans vos paramètres vous allez dans
vos réglages sont et libération une fois
que vous avez votre casque qui est
connecté vous allez dans dolby atmos par
les faux moi j'étais branché en
dynamique je trouve que c'est pascal
mieux pour venir écouter de la musique
vous mettez ben justement dans le
réglage musique je trouve qui est assez
bien et après vous et dans les
préférences de styles équilibre show
nuancé aucune ce que je vous conseille
réellement c'est de vous mettre en
équilibre
vous aurez inspectrice rats
c'est cohérent et vous allez récupérer
du grave si vous voulez récupérer
beaucoup de draps écouter de la musique
électro ou du gros hip hop ce que vous
voulez gros rnb tu peux vous mettre en
show ça va venir un petit peu les
survalorisé c'est un petit peu moins
juste je préfère quand même should une
fois de plus le réglage équilibre qui me
semble quand même beaucoup plus correct
hélas pour moi vous avez comme ça le
réglage qui est vraiment optimales pour
m'être cassé alors ça va dépendre bien
évidemment de ce que vous allez avoir
comme smartphones derrière des réglages
que vous allez pouvoir faire derrière au
niveau de votre casque mais pour moi
c'est vraiment important de venir
optimiser un petit peu le son pensez
bien à bien les introduire au fond de
votre sac répond pas tout au fond de
votre oreille mais bien venir les
intérêts déjà d'une peau les ovations
passive de devenir optimisé l'aspect un
peu ne saurait pas comment dire
peut-être résonance au niveau notamment
des graves ça va rajouter un petit peu
plus de corps à tout ça si vous insérez
pas assez vous allez perdre un petit peu
au niveau des basses et ça vous le
verrez rapidement en fonction fait le
test vous les insérer un peu moins un
peu plus et vous avez tout de suite la
qualité audio va changer de pousser
pales sont trois fonds d'une pente pas
venir vous flinguer les oreilles
deuxième fois pour que le son ne sature
pas trop parce que à pleine puissance et
est forcément l'expérience est un petit
peu diminué au niveau du casque en
lui-même vous retrouver ici votre petit
bouton de volume
vous venez monter son décès leçons vous
avez le bouton milieu qui va me servir
pour à venir à allumer et éteindre
directement la musique plaies et bosses
ça c'est cool
lorsque vous passer des appels
téléphoniques le sont de qualité qui
quand même relativement correct ça
marche bien il ya plutôt un bon son je
vous dis une fois de plus ce n'est pas
de faire un casque premium mais
néanmoins je trouve que la qualité
vraiment au rendez vous et vous avez un
truc qui est assez sympa c'est sur la
partie droite vous êtes un petit bouton
là qui vous permet de faire du double
appareillage ce qui fait que votre cas
ce qui peut être appareillé à deux
appareils en même temps alors vous allez
pas écouté sur deux appareils en même
temps mais par exemple vous écouter d'un
côté s'envole smartphones et d'écouté
vous avez la tablette grâce à ce but on
la faisait pouvoir switcher d'un
appareil à l'autre on va pas forcément
être toujours soin de sa prière même
temps mais en tout cas ça peut avoir un
sens c'est quand même relativement cool
il ya un autre point qui est vraiment
bien avec ce casque là lorsque vous
écoutez de la musique
et lorsque vous voulez rencontrer
quelqu'un par exemple dans la rue à
mattia comment ça se passe vous prenez
vous les enlevez vous les posez ils sont
aimantés dès qu'ils sont connectés est
noté comme ça il se met en pause ce qui
fait que c'est très rapide ça vous évite
d'un attachement bouton je mets la pause
moi je sors mon smartphone je mets la
pause ça c'est direct simple efficace ça
marche en plus lorsque vous vous baladez
comme fabien voyez ça permet de les
garder comme ça très très facilement
tour
coudonc vont une fois de plus c'est un
petit point de départ mais ça fait quand
même la différence
on a donc des écouteurs qui sont sympas
c'est une belle évolution par rapport
aux belette swire laisse première
génération de one plus c'est une montée
en gamme qui est faite là-dessus
notamment au niveau de la qualité audio
je sais pas si ça va bien fonctionner ce
produit de par le système de tour du cou
en tout cas en france probablement dans
d'autres pays dans le monde en france
je ne sais pas et une fois de plus je
vous parle que de la france mais je sais
que vous êtes une grande audience un pas
uniquement en france donc
dites moi une fois de plus dans votre
pays si vous pensez que ce genre de
choses va fonctionner si oui dans quel
pays vous êtes ça m'intéresse vous
marquez tout ça en bas aux commentaires
et puis comment vous les trouvez c'est
owen pluzz bullets wireless de
intéressant oui non pas comment est ce
que vous pourriez aller dessus est ce
que vous êtes allé dessus d'ailleurs
pour un petit peu moins de 100 euros 99
euros/mois je vous dis je trouve que
c'est des conneries qui sont
intéressantes peut-être pour les
personnes qui vont faire du sport du
running qui veulent pas perdre lors leur
casque qui ont peur de perdre justement
des écouteurs trouve ailleurs laisse ce
taux sera peut être vraiment
intéressante tant pis si vous êtes déjà
équipés d'un smartphone one plus à un
sens parce que c'est très facile à
connecter vous avez des réglages sont
optimisés derrière c'est pas mal je
trouve ça assez intéressant pour moi
on n'est pas sur des écouteurs premium
on laisse aux écouteurs qui sont de
bonne facture de bonne qualité avec une
belle montée en gamme de la pardonne
plus cette année au revoir l'année
prochaine s'ils nous sortent des
écouteurs travailleurs laisse aussi 10
restent sur sept types de solutions
autour du cou à voir en tout cas je
pense assez cool et moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire s'il vous
intéresse vous ai mis un lien dans la
description vous les trouverez au tarif
de 99 euros directement son site de
vente plus voilà sur ce je vous embrasse
tous et à demain
ciao